and today i asked
g7 countries
to adopt
legislation
and put in place all necessary
procedures
needed
to seize russian sovereign assets
and give them to ukraine
give them to ukraine
for ukraine to use this money to rebuild
our country to reconstruct
our country after all the damage
inflicted on us canada has already done
so
and
i have a feeling that
others will reach that point
rather sooner than later the assumption
is very simple
russia must pay
politically
economically but also financially
the recipe is clear
more of the same
i mean more support to ukraine
including military support
i will announce that we at the european
union we will provide a new tranche
of
500 more millions
to support military ukraine
if
this package is inclu is adopted without
oil embargo
i believe president putin can celebrate
because it will be the first case when
the unity of the european union will be
broken because of the position of one
country hungary
if
if
theoretically
hungary opts out and
does not support the package
i believe it will cause
a lot of damage on the european union
itself and therefore they have to do
their utmost to prevent it from
happening
continent
what's an important and unique day in
the history of moldova of my country
it's the first time that moldova has
been invited to a g7 meeting like that
that's an honor but at the same time
that's a recognition of the tragic
moments for which
our region is going through
because of the war in ukraine because of
the
russian aggression against ukraine
moldova is ukraine's most fragile
neighbor it's the country that has been
after ukraine the most affected
we have a huge we have a very
uh a series of very negative effects for
our country because of this war on the
economic sphere on the humanitarian
sphere
we had a huge wave of refugees we have
3.5 percent of our population and now
refugees from ukraine
we think that europe's role the role of
the european union is to respond and
keep countries away from war
and that is why we applied for eu
membership we want to get into the
european union we don't want shortcuts
we are making reforms
but we believe that that's the best
answer to ensuring peace on the european
continent is to have democratic peaceful
reformed states uh join forces together
acting together to maintain peace on
european continent so there is no new
dramatic initiative that comes out of
today but we make sure that everything
we agreed in previous visits is on track
where we need to accelerate we
accelerate so it's about refugee
relocation it's about economic
assistance it's about strengthening our
capacity for border management
and it's about our capacity to maintain
socioeconomic uh calm
it's very important at this time
that we keep up the pressure on vladimir
putin
by supplying more weapons to ukraine
by increasing the sanctions
g7 unity has been vital during this
crisis
to protect freedom and democracy and
will continue to work together to do
just that